everyone's just saying how heartbroken
outraged the messages of goodwill from
around to the world just keep coming
comfort to know that we're not fighting
it on our own we're a large family but
were a regular usual family in the UK
you wouldn't
we're not superhuman like anyone else I
said the support means an awful lot it's
really pretty heartwarming
Charlotte's son Harry Dunne was killed
in a collision in August
it happened near RAF Croton in
Northamptonshire an American spy base
police believed that the wife of a US
diplomat drove out of the base on the
wrong side of the road Harry who was on
a motorbike was hit head-on the woman
claimed diplomatic immunity and Sky News
understands that she was told by the US
to leave the country diplomatic immunity
belongs to the state itself it's not
fully individual either to claim it or
to waive it it's a matter for the United
States government to decide whether or
not the immunity applies and decide
whether or not to waive it and that of
course will depend on how close the
individuals work was to the core
functions of a diplomatic mission the
foreign secretary Dominic Rob wants the
u.s. to reconsider their decision he'll
meet with Harry's family soon in a
statement their local MP Andrea led some
said this is an utter tragedy and my
heart goes out to the family and friends
of Harry Dunne who rightly want to get
the justice he deserves I have spoken to
the Foreign Secretary and to Stephen
mold the Northamptonshire police and
crime Commissioner who have promised to
do everything they can to get justice
done the shadow minister for security
Nick Thomas Simmons said this is a
horrendous situation for any pair
my thoughts are with Harry's friends and
family at this terrible time nobody is
above the law I urged the government to
work with the United States Embassy and
do all that can be done to seek justice
for Harry and his family Harry's mum
knows that it's being dealt with at the
highest diplomatic level
she made this appeal to President Trump
just to get him to put her on the plane
sit back and look at the case fully if
he hasn't yet done so I'm sit back and
look what's been left behind to consider
not just the politics side of it but the
fact that there's actually a completely
broken family the US says immunity is
rarely waived and such decisions are
considered carefully given the potential
global impact but this family intend to
fight in the hope that someone with the
power to do something will listen Lisa
Dowd Sky News Northamptonshire